[Música]
la policía encontró sin vida al presunto
autor del tiroteo de Monterrey Park
California que dejó 10 personas muertas
durante una celebración del año nuevo
chino las autoridades lo identificaron
como Who cantrane de 72 años todavía no
está claro el motivo del ataque
miles de personas protestaron en varias
ciudades de Estados Unidos con motivo de
los 50 años del histórico fallo Rover
versus Wake que otorgaba el derecho
constitucional al aborto la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris dijo que
este derecho está amenazado en todo el
país
con un desfile y una colorida ceremonia
acompañada de música Bolivia celebró los
14 años del Estado plurinacional el
presidente Luis Arce participó del
evento apelando a la estabilidad
económica la baja inflación y la
industrialización
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en 24 los saluda
Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados
Unidos las autoridades encontraron sin
vida al presunto asesino de las 10
personas en Monterrey Park California se
trata de Hook and tran de 72 años quien
se habría auto infligido un disparo y su
cuerpo fue hallado en una camioneta
blanca que había usado para huir hasta
el momento no se conoce el móvil del
ataque Samuel Salgado nos cuenta más
una persecución que ya terminó la
policía del Condado de Los Ángeles en
Estados Unidos encontró sin vida el
conductor de una furgoneta sospechoso de
haber matado a 10 personas y por lo
menos herido a otras 10 durante la
celebración del año nuevo chino en
Monterrey Park en la madrugada del
domingo se trata de Hook de 72 años
quien se quitó la vida la búsqueda había
comenzado unas horas antes a unos 40
kilómetros del lugar de los hechos luego
de que una camioneta blanca se vio
involucrada en un enfrentamiento con la
policía de momento no se sabe cuál fue
el móvil del atacante pero la policía
encontró pruebas en el vehículo durante
la búsqueda varias piezas de evidencia
fueron encontradas dentro de la
camioneta vinculando al sospechoso con
ambas locaciones Monterrey Park y Álamo
adicionalmente un arma fue descubierta
dentro de la camioneta
no se ha descartado que se trate de un
acto racista en una ciudad de 61.000
habitantes cuya mayoría es asiática o
asiático americana
es muy sorprendente chocante escuchar
que algo así sucedió no solo en una
ciudad pequeña sino en mi ciudad nunca
piensas que le pasaría a tu pueblo o
algo así
la violencia Armada no es frecuente en
Monterrey Park en un país donde más de
44.000 personas murieron por heridas de
bala en 2022
este domingo se cumplieron 50 años del
fallo histórico Rover versus weight en
Estados Unidos que desde 1973 declaró el
aborto como un derecho constitucional
sin embargo la sentencia fue anulada por
la Corte Suprema en junio pasado y por
ello miles de personas salieron a las
calles de varias ciudades de Estados
Unidos como Nueva York o Madison en
Wisconsin para exigir que se respete el
derecho a la interrupción del embarazo
los estados han estado decidiendo sobre
la legalidad del aborto lo que ha
desatado una lucha en los tribunales y
en el congreso a propósito de la
conmemoración la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris se pronunció para decir que el
derecho al aborto está amenazado en
Estados Unidos
entiendan claramente que la mayoría de
los estadounidenses se oponen a estos
ataques
estadounidenses de todos los orígenes en
cada comunidad han expresado su
perspectiva desde Kansas hasta
California Michigan Montana Kentucky
evermont
hablaron con su voto en esencia dijeron
que uno no tiene que abandonar su fe o
creencias profundamente arraigadas para
aceptar que el gobierno no debería
decirle a la gente que hacer con sus
propios cuerpos
en Bogotá las autoridades detuvieron
este fin de semana a una ciudadana
colombiana sospechosa por el asesinato
del fiscal anticorrupción paraguayo
Marcelo pechi la mujer había sido
expulsada del Salvador según informó la
fiscalía y es señalada de planear
financiar y organizar el homicidio del
fiscal que ocurrió en mayo de 2022 en
las playas de barú en el norte de
Colombia se esperaba que fuera
presentada ante un juez de control de
garantías para avanzar en el proceso de
judicialización
vamos a Bolivia que celebró El
Aniversario número 14 del día del estado
plurinacional durante la jornada se
llevó a cabo un desfile de la fuerza
pública y también una ceremonia
ancestral de agradecimiento a la
pachamama o madre terra que estuvo
dirigida por integrantes del pueblo
aymara El presidente Luis Arce participó
de los eventos e instó a defender la
patria por encima de todo cálculo
político y además apeló a la estabilidad
económica la baja inflación y la
industrialización escuchemos hoy nuestro
estado plurinacional de Bolivia cumple
14 años y celebramos con la alegría
nuestra pluralidad trabajando de manera
Irreversible e irrenunciable hacia un
país más justo libre de racismo y de
toda forma de discriminación y una de
las noticias de la semana fue la
detención de uno de los mejores
jugadores de todos los tiempos el
futbolista brasileño Dani Alves entró en
prisión sin fianza acusado de violación
a una joven de 23 años en los baños de
una discoteca una conmoción y con
crucial que ha ido acompañada de una
rápida actuación de la policía y la
justicia lluís Muñoz con el análisis en
el siguiente informe
el cuadro con más títulos de la historia
del fútbol en prisión preventiva en
España el futbolista brasileño de 39
años Dani Alves está acusado de haber
violado a una joven de 23 años en los
baños de una discoteca de Barcelona la
abogada y activista feminista Nuria
González analizó la decisión judicial en
France 24 atención de Dani Alves viene
dada por la declaración de la víctima
que es muy clara que es totalmente y
sobre todo por las pruebas eso la falta
de arraigo de Dani Alves en España y en
la capacidad económica de Dani Alves
para salir irse y desaparecer donde
quiera es lo que han lo que han hecho
que la jueza prisión preventiva sin
fianza no que es lo que quizá más ha
sorprendido a todo el mundo la policía
revisó las cámaras habló con testigos Y
tomó declaración a la víctima el mismo
día de los hechos esta mantuvo su
versión de forma persistente días
después delante de la jueza por su parte
el exjugador del Fútbol Club Barcelona
Dani Alves cambió tres veces su
declaración y llegó a decir que fue la
víctima quien le asaltó sexualmente
siempre se pone en duda la versión de la
víctima de hecho tristísimo que para que
la víctima tenga más credibilidad en
este caso ella ha decidido renunciar a
su derecho a una indemnización para que
nadie vaya a decir que es que está en
esto por dinero es absolutamente
denigrante que una víctima tenga que
renunciar a sus derechos para ser para
tener más credibilidad entonces Dani
Alves cuando hace gala de esa soberbia
pues está un poco en lo cierto porque
claramente vemos que las versiones de
las mujeres siempre se ponen en duda
Dani Alves estará en prisión preventiva
hasta que se celebre el juicio la ley en
España contempla apenas de entre 4 a 12
años de cárcel para este tipo de delitos
Mientras tanto el equipo del que Dani
Alves formaba parte en el momento de los
hechos El Pumas mexicano rescindió su
contrato y finalizamos con noticias de
una experiencia que solo ocurre cada
50.000 años y ahora es el momento de
verlo durante el mes de enero y
principios de febrero un cometa de color
verde brillante será visible en nuestros
cielos la última vez que visitó nuestro
vecindario cósmico los near aún
caminaban en la tierra aquí les contamos
llegó por última vez a nuestro sistema
solar hace 50.000 años El Cometa C 2022
e3ztf se está acercando al planeta
Tierra También conocido como El Cometa
verde fue recientemente descubierto en
la órbita de Júpiter se acercó al sol en
enero y desde Entonces comenzó a
dirigirse a nuestro vecindario
tiene varios kilómetros de diámetro es
absolutamente minúsculo como un pequeño
asteroide congelado una bola de nieve
sucia que se encuentra a 42 millones de
kilómetros Así que es minúsculo No
veremos el cometa en sí lo que podemos
ver Es lo que ocurre a su alrededor la
desgasificación que puede extenderse a
lo largo de millones de kilómetros es
por eso que el Cometa se hace visible
es de color verde debido a las moléculas
de carbono diatómico que al desprenderse
del núcleo del Cometa terminan
desintegradas por Los Rayos UV del Sol
una que produce luz verde sin embargo El
Cometa no será visible sin un cielo
despejado y poca contaminación lumínica
estará en su punto más cercano a la
tierra el primero de febrero y con el
regreso de la luna al cielo nocturno el
25 de enero El Cometa verde será más
visible en mitad de la noche una vez que
la luna se haya puesto hasta que es
informativo en France 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos pero los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web triple W
punto franz24.com para seguir la
actualización de nuestras noticias
quédense con nosotros
[Música]